[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hi
there, everybody.
What's up?
My name is Magnus, and you're
watching Cording TensorFlow--
the show where you learn
how to code in TensorFlow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
In this episode, we'll talk
about saving and loading
models.
So why do we want
to talk about this?
Well, first of all,
whenever you train
a model of any
significant complexity,
the training can
take a long time.
Most of the models in this
Getting Started series
will just take a
minute or so to train,
where real-life models can take
days or even weeks to train.
So if you were to hit
Control-C on your training job
after it's been running
for a day or so,
all your model weights
and values will be lost,
and you would have to restart
training from the beginning
and be a very sad camper.
But if you saved your
model every so often,
you can always resume
training from that point,
making you a happy camper.
Another benefit is that
you can take your model
and transfer to
another computer, where
you can continue training.
But I'm pretty sure you
already guessed that I
was going to bring that up.
That's enough talking for now.
Check out the links
below to locate the code,
because that's what
we're going to do now.
Check out the code!
Oh, finally!
We get to check out the code!
That's awesome!
Let's go and check out the code!
All right.
Let's start by checking out
the awesome licenses here
at the top.
Then install packages for
HDF5 and JAML support.
And here we do some imports, and
print the TensorFlow version.
It's totally OK if you have
a later version than me here.
We use the MNIST data
set to demonstrate
model loading and saving.
Then reshape the
images to batches of 28
by 28 arrays, which is the
pixel size of MNIST images,
and normalize all pixel
values to be between 0 and 1.
Next is the model
definition, which
is defined in the
create_model function.
This is a very
basic model, which
is totally OK, because
in this screencast
we're interested in learning
how to load and save models,
not creating the best model
for the MNIST dataset.
And here, we finally get to
see how a model can be saved.
checkpoint_path will be the
path of the saved model.
A model checkpoint
callback object
is created with this path.
We also specify that only
the weights of the model
should be saved, and
that we want debug output
when the saving is performed.
Finally, we perform
the model training
by calling the fit method
and providing this callback.
As you can see, this
will cause a model
to be saved once every
epoch has been completed.
And if we look at the
checkpoints directory,
we can now see three files.
The cp.ckpt.data file contains
all the weight values.
This file has a range sequence,
because multiple partitions
could potentially be used
if we have a lot of weights.
The cp.ckpt.index file
specifies which partition file
contains which weights.
And finally, the checkpoint
file is a text file that
points to the latest model.
In our case, we only
have one data file,
but shortly, we'll
see an example
where we have saved multiple
versions of the model.
All right.
So now when we have
our saved model,
let's try out loading it.
First, let's just create a model
from scratch and try it out.
Since it hasn't
been trained, you
can see that the
accuracy really sucks.
And now for the magic.
If we call the
method load_weights
with our checkpoint
path, our model
gets initialized with the
previous training state,
and has much better accuracy.
OK.
That's the basics to
save and load models.
Let's look at some
more options we have.
One option is to provide
the period parameter
when creating the model
checkpoint object.
In this case we use the
value 5, which as you can see
saves a new model
every five epochs.
Observe in this case, we also
use a parameterized filing
based on the epoch.
This means a unique file
is saved every time.
That's also why we can see
multiple files when looking
at the checkpoint directory.
We can also use
a function called
tf.train.latest_checkpoint that
will return the latest model,
which was saved--
in our case, the
one with index 50.
This function looks into the
file with the name checkpoint
to find the latest checkpoint.
Remember that the checkpoint
file is a text file,
so you can actually check
the file content yourself.
And now we can load the model
using the load_weights function
like we did before,
providing the value returned
by tf.train.latest_checkpoint.
Another way of saving models
is to call the save method
on the model.
This will create an
HDF5-formatted file.
Remember that we specified
save_weights_only
to true last time
we saved a model.
In addition to only
saving variables,
the save method saves
additional data,
like the model's configuration
and even the state
of the optimizer.
A model that was saved using the
save method can be loaded with
the function
keras.models.load_model.
And as you can see, we have the
accuracy of a trained model.
In addition to everything
we've looked at,
TensorFlow also has a very
important file format,
called SavedModel.
This is a file
format that allows
to exchange models between many
different parts of TensorFlow,
like TensorFlow
Python, TensorFlow.js,.
And also TensorFlow Lite.
We are currently building
out first-hand support
for SavedModel in Keras, and you
can check out the links below
to read more about it.
And that's it for this
episode of Coding TensorFlow.
Make sure to subscribe
to the channel
to get more videos like this.
Now it's your turn to
go out there and create
some great models.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]